I want to make a film about police but
not your normal the world is kind of
full rather an experiment a stunt a
challenge for change the idea here is
that if a surfer this is my mate Jordi
can air and ran away and land in a
floating trash can and why can't you
waste
[Music]
[Music]
gotcha sorry this is a wait before we
get into that let's talk facts which are
boring I know she has an Italian yoga
instructor instead
did you know there is an island of
garbage twice the size of Texas in the
Pacific Ocean
there are 25 trillion pieces of plastic
debris in the ocean this is killing more
than a hundred thousand marine animal
and a million bird if JD Smith can run
and land into the trash
why cannot your waste do the same we
created the first two circular pieces
one is going to create the base and the
other one is going to create the rim
[Music]
I reckon I can answer this thing to be
honest pretty saddening when you're
paddling back at it and you see tons of
of litter in the ocean the ocean
something that's really really dear to
me
I mean it's given me basically a whole
my I don't have a solution but I know
these need to change and therefore I'm
I'm here to inspire conversation i'm
jordi smith and let's talk track
[Music]
[Music]
no no it's so hard to get in there just
with about a speed that you come in with
really really praying and hoping that we
can just get him in there
[Music]
oh I think we struck gold I think that's
about as good as you can get this is not
about the solution I know that there are
restrictions weights and on government
facilities like not enough charge cans
in public areas and mismanagement of
different waste streams and upcycling
and recycling but this isn't about being
hopeless or pushing the blame this is
rather about a group of like-minded
changemakers coming together and talking
about possible solutions I've linked a
URL through the Lud's talk trash site
below and this is just in the
development phases of an idea that can
become something great and we need your
halt so please get involved and let's
create this thing together also please
let me know what you thought about this
video in the comments below and don't
forget to Like and subscribe just
[Music]